without further Ado here are my absolute
favorites from 2020.
well now because you moved it so high
a woman is bossy oh yeah poor women
anyways because we made one of these
one of these feminism commercials okay
so he's persuasive she's she's pushy she
said women have it so hard in this
country
that's why they live longer and make up
most college students right
it's because of how hard they have it
you know she's selfish
meat and vain oh yeah
yeah we never give women credit for
their physical Beauty no never not this
country
it's a show-off yeah wow you know what
you know what you know who does that to
women other women there's no guy going
uh this girl that when a woman looks
beautiful there's no man going to show
off no he's like damn she looks
beautiful he might be like damn cat
calling or he might be like wow she
looks so nice what a lovely woman but
you know what you know the only person
who's calling a woman dressed like that
a beaut beautiful who took time to put
herself together a show-off is a jealous
broad that's who's doing it this is also
stupid because this is all against the
patriarchy that isn't really against us
down with the patriarchy we're a lady
today I'll put the patriarchy I have no
idea don't let labels hold you back
I have no I have no idea what this is
be strong and shine what is this even
for
Pantene prove me shampoo not even a hint
not everybody wakes up happy
sometimes you feel sad scared crappy
yeah oh this is gonna be a wrap
I can sense is that you let me feel my
way
a woman's called a spanker this is a
Pantene can't wait to leave this closed
minded town
a rural America
himself
she seems lovely
[Music]
all right what is this a commercial for
Mom
this is like very generically liberal
I don't I don't know it's not just like
only feminist or something
Lexapro it's like a moving company my
student loan
I'm never moving out of my parents home
just got ghosted
should have known
pretty sure I'm gonna say something like
a moving company because it's all about
moving and leaving I'm too young to
raise my baby girl
take your opinions and suck world
it's actually kind of nice that she
raised the kid and didn't do abortion or
something yeah I agree this is so
negative that's pretty good they think
it's woke but it's not it's actually
pretty conservative the one guys sad
because he can't pay his loans and he's
living in his parents house the girls
sat like angry because the world is
judging her because she's a young mother
you know like second world you know I'm
gonna Raise Myself Away I'm still gonna
stick with like a moving something
this is the longest commercial ever
[Music]
yeah no one is happy all the time
that's okay
[Laughter]
is that a a Burger King that [ __ ] will
make you depressed eating Burger King
the irony that's so ironic that's
incredible wow that food is so bad for
your mental health wow brain fog just
terrible for your overall health 95 of
like whatever like chemicals go to your
brain come from your stomach the gut
mind connection you should look that up
yeah you should probably well maybe not
tonight but we'll find a video on the
gutmine connection and then he first
said that everybody can just learn the
basic science it's ancient Chinese
medicine actually it's like two three
thousand years old they understood that
but we don't accept Eastern medicine
here in the universe I can't figure out
why we're sat yeah it's crazy Burger
King I guess a Happy Meal like uh I
guess there's a tie in there oh my gosh
and then at the end Burger King supports
the work of
mentalhealthamerica.net that I you know
there's something very distasteful about
that I like the pun of it's a Happy Meal
and no one's happy all the time but to
explain it wasn't quite going through
like clinical depression and we're
feeling suicide to sell a cheap
hamburger they said I was too pretty to
fight now she can't fight you're gonna
mess up that beautiful face they said I
was too fat only skinny girls can dress
well
speak that language who told you not to
dress well nobody nobody told a girl
you're fat don't bother putting on nice
clothes nobody said that ever no one
says you're fat you should only wear
oversized t-shirts and sweatpants like I
mean this is what I'm talking about they
just they make up problems that don't
even exist and then like not for nothing
that that Burger King commercial didn't
make me feel heard because I'm sad
sometimes it just made me feel like it
was a depressing commercial it doesn't
make me it doesn't associate positive
feelings just from a sheer advertising
standpoint you want to associate your
business with something that makes
people's lives easier or makes them feel
better just made me feel worse about
Burger King that I didn't I never saw
that commercial before and we don't
really watch a lot of network TVs but
maybe it was an online commercial still
still didn't see it the [ __ ] tell me
about me I said my nose was too promised
I said I was too masculine I thought the
cat calling was a compliment he said you
can fix those teeth quite easily boyish
and ugly when they were talking about
female they weren't talking about me
this was not pretty they would haul it
from across the street looks
sophisticated embarrassing nose too
chubby it was too skinny man like crazy
too beautiful too fast
I said no way you aren't me
I'm me I'm not gonna be defined by
anyone's expectations
I dress myself the way I am because my
face has nothing to do with my box and
I'm ranked number one in the country
number two in the world as a fashion
blogger my style is 100 honorable
fashion like you want to change my team
nothing they've said has meant anything
it's like I'm not you I'm me this is my
hair my beauty my beauty my beauty
what's what's the point here
no idea what is this ad for
I had platitude
who wrote this commercial it's like
there's this there's this click hole
advertising campaign it was like you
know one of these satirical things was
like are you going to take the pledge
take the pledge I take the pledge for my
community I take the pledge for my I
take the pledge for me right and then
you get to the end and there's they're
not pledging anything that was that this
commercial but unironically she's like
I'm mate you know what not only are
these shallow they're trying so hard to
be deep that they're Shadow shallow
they're boring these are boring yeah
they're not even good commercials I
don't care about all this sadness why
does this generation want to be up to
their necks in misery at all times oh
this is not new
oh it happened before
in every downturn it's been proven cloth
masks don't do anything gender equality
has been set back as women gender
equality Oh I thought this is not new
with the mask
what is the front line care move the pay
cuts more of the jobs lost more of the
responsibilities at home keeping them
from going back to paid work these times
are not unprecedented but they give us
another chance for equality if we all
choose to step forward as equals
model equal do equal choose equal what
is it going to be card I don't know I'm
just like Hail Mary it's like a credit
card I don't know foreign
[Music]
ah Procter and Gamble wait Procter
Gamble Gillette oh I guess like all
those companies you know that was a
total it was stupid and also negative
Debbie Downer showing women in the in
the in the factory you guys are so
empowering who said that
that is not a
custom word and you were going to hear
it nothing I can do about that but you
are not gonna let that word hurt you
imagine they actually told people that
imagine they actually told them to not
let the words hurt you instead of going
and riding and crying and well let's see
what the word is I'm sorry but they they
don't teach you that anymore they don't
teach you to have any skin yeah exactly
exactly yeah that's what happens all the
time right white people just always
calling black guys the n-word all the
time that's just yeah the only time you
actually hear the n-word by the way is
in rap music but good driver yeah they
call it they call each other getting a
ticket this is about you not coming home
oh yeah racist cops just uh Slaughter
innocent black people all over the
country you know that of course that's
what always happens
and statistically it doesn't
have a dozen times you were beautiful
unarmed and unarmed by the way doesn't
it be not justified but one for another
time never forget that
let's talk about the talk I'm putting on
these glasses
cancer coming through the screen right
now the Proctor and Gamble again
my black is beautiful
my white is beautiful
about that is this going to help us this
will help the cancer from getting into
our eyeballs you okay
I'm good I'm good shut up
[Music]
it could be a car commercial
it's a car commercial dude
[Music]
a little lesbian I think they're
lesbians right I guess
it could be like a home insurance
commercial
[Music]
Mom this is Amy Amy
hey Dad
hey I'm Amy hi nice to meet you
are you hungry oh that white guy doesn't
like the lesbian thing
of course he doesn't that was darn way I
love how they made him white too like
they intentionally made the mom black
and then the dad white because he's the
white there is an agenda against white
people it is so true like they go off
and they talk about how you're gonna
hear what they tell these black people
you're gonna hear white people calling
you the n-word like bro yes it might
happen sometimes it's just gonna happen
but the amount that like white people
get called it's like like people they
call them after white people for being
white is way more than the [ __ ] black
people get for being black from white
people that's just the [ __ ] truth
come on like I know you can't say this
right now but that's how that's the
truth
[Music]
is something gonna happen
[Music]
dad's happy to see the straight kids he
just doesn't like the lesbians okay
now
[Music]
okay okay
[Music]
bro nobody cares if a white neighbor
lady doesn't like the white the white
neighbor lady also doesn't like it
actually really hates the [ __ ] irony
of that is the white neighbor lady is
the book probably the most liberal flag
waving just it she'll wave any flag for
any cause just to make herself feel like
she's got a uh some value on this planet
yeah
hey Don
night night good night
kind of like over the top even if it was
a straight couple like you're unmarried
you're like lying around kissing each
other and your parents asked
it's not like really acceptable
[Music]
sharing a bed unmarried you can't no
wonder that dad's upset what's he doing
it's like a movie I have no idea what
it's like there isn't a product yeah
right
did I do it right
oh no
do you like it it's a home insurance
Oreos Oreos does for Oreo cookies it was
beautiful okay let's talk just strictly
about the fact that it's a cookie
commercial which has it's just about
cookies why does everything have to be
so deep when did he when did life get to
be where every single thing has to be
this big meaningful act that's not
reality you know people blow their nose
they go to the bathroom they they brush
their teeth they think everything isn't
meaningful
cookies junk food junk food now has to
be this big meaning so you're a proud
parent why you think Oreo gives a flying
[ __ ] about that no they don't but they
have to they have some young people that
work there that made this a top priority
in their marketing that did not sell any
extra cookies none and we're gonna see
all of this advertising disappear watch
it watch as the as the things keep
rolling we already talked about Netflix
how they have figured out that that
they're overly woke programming
alienated a lot of people and not even
because people are hateful because we
tired of having everything mean such a
big deep thing and not we just want to
be entertained we just want to eat a
[ __ ] cookie without having a you feel
like I'm I'm participating in some big
social movement or or shunning a big
social movement stop it enough this is
this is all going to backfire they're
not they're not going to continue down
this path because it's not good for
business get back to telling me that
that cookie is going to make me happy in
my tummy and then I'll buy the cookie
[Music]
the usual one is like it's like the mom
water boys
I don't even know what's going on here
maybe it's that there we go
all right first one change that's an
extra piece of candy oh
I think I see where this is going they
live in like an elementary school it's
like you can't do the different races
like superheroes is that right look at
the house
[Music]
[Music]
and I know what's happening here
another cookie commercial I guess Mr
Blue Dress is Wonder Woman and the girls
is that what it is
[Music]
seven minutes
okay probably is the candy thing again
right
like the the people so far this just
feels like you know people
they don't they sleep in their clothes
in their Halloween clothes they passed
out that you know what sometimes you
don't wake a kid are you oh yeah
freaking kidding me there you go
called it
they're going to trans the kids they're
going to make us trans the freaking kids
it's so creepy so proud the dad looks so
proud my kid was Wonder Woman my son
my boy
that's my boy I'm in my girl nope my
girl thank you what do you give those
one out of ten
hero
on [ __ ] they get
it
[Music]
[Music]